and Dana's making a belt fort just for
that like the People's Champ belt Oh
like the street huh well well date what
Nate says is the baddest [ __ ] in
the game belt yeah that's what that's
what he's making that can't say that you
gonna say that on TV yes man can't say
baddest [ __ ] in the game major
psyche the hardcores belt you know yeah
that's the that's the [ __ ] it I'm so
happy they made that fight I didn't
think was gonna happen - anything's
gonna happen when I saw it on my
Instagram feed this morning I threw my
arms up in the air like somebody got
knocked out I was like well when I saw
you at the improv I was like I don't
think it's gonna happen there I feel
like that Nate needs too much money it's
too much he says it's worth money well
you know Dana said something you know
I'd said that I think that that Nate
Diaz is one of the biggest superstars in
the game right up there with everybody
easy top five yes and then Nate and I
guess there were some negotiations or
something cuz Dana refuted it goes well
I don't think that Nate Diaz in our
long-term plans and Nate fights once
every three years and Mike don't say
that that could be him playing the game
yes I'm trying to learn made out I'm
like come on Nate and also let him know
that look we got other plans there's
other [ __ ] we do you know I just
retweeted it oh you did okay what is the
link I don't know is it the powerful
Jerry page yeah it's on there but it's
not that link we have I'm just excited
but I want us mom versus uh vs. Colby
that's the fight to make a hundred
percent that cards stacked though even
without lucemon Kobe I hope they worked
that out cuz I wanna see that but Mazda
ball Nate you just I'll just buy that
fight I don't you guys those two guys
not only are they - the baddest
[ __ ] ever but they're funny is
[ __ ]
they're both great they're funny they're
both super necessary yeah all that [ __ ]
three piece in a soda
I named a move a transition three piece
and so brilliant
after habits kid I showed it to him to
learn this I gotta know it he's three
piece with the soda that guy is so good
he's so good and so he's so clever
you know that's one of the best things
to say about Maz Woodall and the thing
is people don't necessarily associate
him with knockout power for some reason
yet the guy knocked out Eve AdWords with
a head kick he knocked out Darren tail
cowboy Cerrone yes no tell Ben Askren
and put him in another dimension with a
flying knee world record fastest
knockout I mean it's weird that people
don't associate Maz Vidal with a
knockout artist because he doesn't have
he doesn't necessarily have the most
power but he's so good it's so
calculated the way he set up that knee
is this the card yes the Kelvin versa
details interesting
Derek Lutz Lewis versus blog knee Eve
novel Johnny Walker Corey Anderson look
boy but look I forget I forget how to
say that guy's name blog all have enough
even off I think it's even even off he's
a scary dude he is so scary yet staff
yeah in the heart bro stamina heart
Corey Anderson Johnnie Walker's a good
fight but dude Johnnie Walker shoulders
still [ __ ] up I sent you that video of
him working out he's the mobilities not
great well he's also he's throwing
punches with only one arm he's not in
the videos of him working out and then
there's other videos of him going
through strength and conditioning and
you see what he's doing with his left
arm and I'm like Jesus Christ is like
he's not lifting any weight with his
left arm hopefully he's all right how
about freakin Kelvin versatil that's
Hill was like nah man let me just go
after these [ __ ] monsters well he
legitimately is a middleweight I mean he
that guy was killing himself making one
seven I agree but why but coming off
that the two losses that he suffered and
then you know obviously either he had
some issues while in a lab in Liverpool
and wherever Bali or whether Hebrew in
that hotel I don't so he's going through
something and then they just give them
frickin well I think he asked for Kelvin
I don't care god I'm a fan I'm [ __ ]
I'm both both those guys well Kelvin is
so good I think cameras now better was
my favorite middleweight fight of all
for her which is